RoboCop was one of the great Sci-Fi
movies in the late 80s it is really up
there with the Predator Terminator and
so on
but could they actually be about to make
a decent sequel welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so for a couple of years now there's
been this project of Robocop returns
bouncing around
this is actually a movie based on the
original Creator store it's a sequel
that was actually supposed to happen
years ago based on a script written in
the early 90s Paul the Hoven was
supposed to retake the helm the original
writers like Michael Miner and Edward
numera can't say that name
had actually created a script and a
couple of none guys had come in and
modernized revamped that original but
that has been stuck in development help
directors of common Garden creators have
left Paul verhoven has no idea and
really it's kind of been stuck but I
hear things from MGM and this is a
product the MGM own I've told there's
been a massive rethink by Amazon
and the RoboCop project is about to get
back on the rails
oh by the way guys don't forget to like
subscribe hit that Bell notification
share the video wherever the hell you
want and if you enjoy the content please
consider hitting the join button also
you can go to sign dashtrack.com and buy
marvelous merchandise like the T-shirt
I'm wearing today you can pick Rock
which is it you can pick which SG team
you want to join people like to see
reboots I know people get irritated by
it but at the end of the day people go
to see them the hardest thing to do when
you've created a new movie or a new
franchise or new anything is to get
people excited about it in the first
place an easy way to cut that problem
out is just to revamp something that
people already love now in the last few
years Movie Makers have tried to do this
and failed quite badly uh Blade Runner
2049 was an absolute pile of crap and so
was the last couple of Terminator movies
but they keep trying we are going to be
getting Beverly Hills Cop 4 in the next
six months we're going to be getting a
live-action He-Man movie something I'm
unnaturally excited about but Heman was
always my favorite when I was a kid
He-Man with cartoons are just the
greatest and as long as I keep Kevin
Smith away from the live action version
I'll be happy I think there is also a
very big Robocop game coming back next
year and that actually Paul Weller has
actually done some filming for and is
actually going to appear in the game
should be awesome and when that hits I
should imagine between now and then
they'll also want the movie to follow it
quite quickly
RoboCop has had a revamp before it had a
reboot Michael Keaton was actually quite
good in it but why did it fail well it's
really simple
it was bad
they tried to copy certain elements from
the original verhoven movie but I tried
to do it in a 12a rating which was just
ridiculous the original RoboCop was
shocked that was the point it was an
adult movie it was an 18 rating
20 seconds to comply
I think you'd better do what he says Mr
Kenny
[Music]
there are parts that feeling
particularly the start where Murphy
obviously gets taken down by the gang
and gets his arm blown off and it felt
that are genuinely shocking it's quite
actually difficult to watch even today
the special effects dodging in a few
places but that whole sequence was done
phenomenally well and there are stories
about even the actors throwing up during
filming because it was so violent and so
realistic
what is this [ __ ] also the design of the
robot cop was just crap he looks stupid
and it's one of those things again isn't
it that apparently they have actors when
they sign on to franchises like this
they actually have in their contracts
how much of their faces to be seen for
how much percentage of the movie and
this is one reason why constantly the
helmet opens up and you can see his full
face
I hated it actually in the original
movie when he finally emerges and he
takes the helmet off but I can see why
they did it because it was about trying
to make the RoboCop more human and
Murphy retaking his Humanity they didn't
bother with that in the sequel I think
it was 2011. it was just crap
um he's constantly has his face open
another thing that I really hated about
the rebooted movie was the very clever
but very boring problem between which is
actually in control man or machine that
the computer system could override
Murphy basically and take over
now that was sort of implied in the
original movie I mean we had the prime
directives and things but it was still
Murphy it had his memories wiped they
did start to slowly come back
in this version in the rebooted version
the way they did that was overly
complicated very very technical and it
was supposed to be I think quite big
thinking that you know it was supposed
to be a metaphor about the reality and
the the the relationship between man and
machine that we have in the modern world
but it just didn't work and it was
actually kind of boring I really think
any new rebooted version of Robocop
needs to be far more violent far more
aggressive far more shocking and really
it should cut down to the bone you know
that was another thing from the RoboCop
movie when we have little flashes of him
that you know put in the uh suntan
lotion on
um they tried again to copy that in the
2011 version but they didn't
shock enough they didn't go far enough
they didn't have that I'll buy that for
a dollar kind of scene which you know
made you stop and think instead it felt
like it felt forced it felt a bit woke
so how could the RoboCop movie work well
I think it should be RoboCop Next
Generation Now apparently they were
trying to get Paul Weller to come back
but the man's in his 70s he refused
but what they wanted to do was do the
old Robocop and basically have you know
the new ones coming through behind him
and then one of the enemies was going to
be one of the robocops that you know
turned against him or something which to
me would have been a bit too close to
the script for what we've actually
already seen in RoboCop 2 because that's
basically what happened
but I would like to see a movie that was
a direct sequel to RoboCop 2. let's
forget all the other things that
happened like the TV series and a couple
of TV movies they did and and that
RoboCop 3 movie which was just awful
where he's flying around at the end
forget let's forget that ever happened
but I would like to see an actual sequel
to the original robocops you know we're
getting the game so let's get something
that works with the game you know let's
get something as well that it does feel
a bit retro does feel a little
old-fashioned even in the way it's made
that was another problem with the new
RoboCop movie that they had him being
very fast and jumping round and being
able to jump and things now I know why
they did it we all see on YouTube these
videos from Boston Dynamics these robots
that can jump around like little ninjas
but it kind of took something away the
Wayne RoboCop moved in the original one
the sound that how you how heavy he
sounds you know he's walking along
that kind of made him cool you know he
didn't jump around and prance around
like a [ __ ] deer he was a robot you
know and that made him really cool but
if they can actually make a movie that's
a bit retro that's incredibly violent
and shocking I mean I want to come away
from this movie going
did they need to do that because you
know that's that's that's what we did
from the original you know when the car
goes through that guy there's Daxton
chemicals and he pops we all when we
first saw the movie went Jesus did they
really need to do that did they did they
actually do that I remember going to
school next day and going oh my God I'm
just in Robocop but this happened and my
mates go no you know it's got to be a
little bit shocking now that's going to
be quite difficult in the modern age but
if you're creative and you're brave
enough you can do what Deadpool did for
the Marvel movies you can do something
that does stand out from the crowd what
are they gonna do replace us
[Music]
so what do you think do you want to see
a RoboCop reboot is this a character you
need to see on your screens if they do
it properly or should they just leave it
alone the original is great the second
one was okay that'll do
get in the comments and tell me exactly
what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and don't forget if you enjoy the
content please consider becoming a fully
fledged side tracker I don't want to
rely on YouTube's pennies
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
[Music]